اندونيسيا حيث صار بركان كرينشي اعلى جبل
في جزيره سومطره صباح اليوم
وتصاعد دخانهم من الفوهه بارتفاع 70 مئه
متر ورفع المركز الاندونيسي لعلوم
البراكين ومراقبه الكوارث الجيولوجيه حاله
الخطر من بركان جبل كرينشي الى درجه الخطر
الثانيه من بين اربعه مستويات التاهب
من صفوحي
جبل سيميرو في محافظه لومانج شرقيه جزيره
جاوا الاندونيسيا ينضم الينا مراسلنا صهيب
جاسم صهيب يعني الصوره تشرح كثيرا حدثنا
اكثر عن المعطيات والمشاهداتك
نعم كما ذكرتم نحن الان امام ظواهر
جيولوجيه لافته جدا من من من من بركان
السميرون هنا نحن نقف عند سفوحه الى بركان
كرنتي وغيرها وهناك زلزال ايضا وقع في
منطقه تقع جنوب شرق هذه المنطقه لم يقع
فيها هذه القريه هي قريه كاجر كونغ وهي
ابرز القرى المتضرره من الثوران البركاني
الذي وقع فجر الاحد نلاحظ هنا هذا التراب
الاسود هو الرمادي البركاني الذي زحف نحو
هذه المنطقه من سفوح الجبل طبعا الجبل
سيميرو يقع في الجهه في تلك الجهه الى
الشمال الغربي ورؤيته الان محجوبه بسبب
الغيوم والضباب الرماد البركاني والحيطان
البركاني تدحرجه وانسكب من ذلك الاتجاه
نحو نحو هذه المنطقه وهذا اللون الاسود هو
الرمادي البركاني ونرى سخونته واضحه لحد
الان طبعا الثوران البركاني مستمر يقع من
وقت الى اخر وقع اليوم ظهرا وامس ظهرا
وليلى ايضا وهذا ما دفع السلطات الى اخلاء
السكان هنا المنازل
كم الهائل من الرمادي البركاني الذي تدفق
على هذه المنطقه ودفن عشرات المنازل العام
الماضي من اللافت ان هذا امر حصل لقريه
مجاوره لهذه القريه ودفن حينها اكثر من
5000 منزل وقتل العشرات وجرح لمئات هذه
المره يتحدث تتحدث فرق الانقاذ على انها
نجحت وتحمد الله على انها نجحت بابعاد
السكان عن اي قتل او سقوط قتل قتل بسبب
الانذار المبكر الذي وقع مساء يوم السبت
قبل ان يحصل الثوران الاكبر فجر الاحد هذه
المنطقه الملاحظه ان الدمار واضح هذا
الطريق كان هذا الطريق كان يوصل بين
محافظتين اليوم فقط صباحا جاءت معدات
ثقيله
وازالت كميات كبيره جدا من الرماد
البركاني وصار من الممكن للمواطنين للعوده
عبر هذا الطريق واخر الامتعتهما المنطقه
شبه خاليه من المواطنين هناك عدد قليل من
الفرق الانقاذ المسؤولين والمتطوعين من
الهيئه الوطنيه للتعامل مع اثار الكوارث
وهي تحاول ان تبعد المواطنين وتعطيهم
وتعيدهم بعطائهم منازل البديله عن منازلهم
في هذه القريه وقد منح بعض المواطنين فعلا
منازل بديله عن هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن
المخاوف من امكانيه ثوران البركان بشكل
مستمر وهذا ثوران طبعا لا احد يستطيع
التاكد منه لكن هناك مؤشرات تدل عليها من
خلال اجهزه الجسم جراف والكاميرات
المراقبه الموجوده في اماكن بعيده اقرب
الى البركان وبالتالي الحكومه لا تريد
للمواطنين يعودوا لهذه المنطقه ويعتقدون
انها خطره وفعلا المواطنين يشعرون بان هذه
المنطقه لم تعد امنه بنسبه لهم يتحدث
الينا سكان ان هناك ثورانا وقع في قديم
الزمان قبل عشرات السنين وكان مجرى الرماد
من هذا الطريق ثم تغير في السنوات الاخيره
الى جهه اخرى واليوم عاده عاده الرماد
البركاني بهذا الاتجاه هناك تحذيرات من
استمرار هذا الثوران طبعا نتحدث عن سميره
وهو اعلى قمه جبل البركاني
في اندونيسيا ومن حيث الجبال بركاء في جو
عفوا ومن حيث الجبال البركانيه وغير
البركانيه هو الرابع في اندونيسيا ونتحدث
كما ذكرت في مقدمه الخبر عن ثوران بركان
اكبر هو كرينشي هو الاعلى في جزيره
السمطره وعن زلازل وقعت في الجنوب الشرقي
من هذه المنطقه على الساحل الجنوبي باتجاه
المحيط الهندي كلها ظواهر جيولوجيه تدفع
السلطاتها الاهتمام بهذا الامر وتدفع
المواطنين للبحث عن بدائل في قضايا
الزراعه والتجاره وغيرها والانتقال من هذه
المنطقه هم يامنون ان ان الحكومه ستمنعهم
همم
وكما ذكرت منحرف بالفعل بعض الناس منازل
عن هذه المنطقه وهناك امل بانهم يجدوا
مجال الحياه في اماكن اخرى في شرق الجزيره
الشرقيه
شكرا لك